- This is some news sung,
instead of spoken.
In bad news...
♫Farrah Abraham
♫Is getting a boob job
♫To fix her boob job
♫Poor Farrah Abraham♫
In good news...
(drum sticks hitting)
♫The Gilmore Girls are
coming back to Netflix
♫And 30-year-old women all
around the world rejoice♫
In bad news...
♫Donald Trump is still talking
♫Saying terrifically stupid things
♫And we can't stop
♫Paying attention♫
In good news...
(drum sticks hitting)
♫We totally think we found aliens
♫It's like a star and it flickers
♫It's so totally aliens
♫It's like a superstructure
♫Like a big old scaffolding around a star♫
I'm super amped about it, super amped.
- So exciting, we'll
get hoverboards finally.
- Oh, for sure.
Also good news,
♫Star Wars♫
(sigh)
Took me six hours to get tickets though.
Oh, Yoda.
That's it.